sixteen Summer Olympics are in full
swing
which means sports fans have lots to
celebrate and argue about online so here
to fill us in on who deserves gold and
groans this week is nightly show
contributor Franchesca Ramsey with
another installment of hash it out
thanks Larry this year's US women's
gymnastics team made us all proud by
taking home the gold for Team all-around
but before we could even start
celebrating this epic win Twitter had a
meltdown because Gabby Douglas didn't
put her hand over her heart during the
national anthem take a look at some of
these tweets if Gabby Douglas is not
patriotic enough to honor her country
then she needs to find another sponsor
and go home with them not patriotic
enough homegirl literally did backflips
wearing our nations flag covered in
rhinestones and I don't care what you
say sir there is nothing more patriotic
than a choreographed tribute to the
bedazzler
how dare Gabby Douglas not put her hand
on her heart for the American National
Anthem
hashtag kick Gabby out of the Olympics
kick her out of the Olympics ah there is
no way this guy could get any worse or
so I thought until I saw his Twitter
profile but I guess I'm not surprised
that a trump supporter wants to deport a
brown person doing work he's not
qualified to do she's completely showing
respect by standing there proudly during
the national anthem how about you show
some respect for somebody who made it
possible for the national anthem to be
playing in the first place
maybe maybe Gabi's arms were tired do
you know how much energy you would spend
doing bit level gymnastics hell this is
me after walking up four flights of
stairs
but the national anthem backlash wasn't
even the worst of it
Twitter took the gold medal and petty
when people started dragging Gabby for
her hair I just want a black girl to do
Gabby Douglas's hair bro that's it guess
what bro
a black girl did Gabby's hair Gabby how
does Gabby Douglas mother even let her
be on national television with those
edges looking like that
Gabby Douglas got money and then edges
horrible no what's horrible is them
Grammer you got okay let me just explain
edges edges is another word for hairline
and when it comes to black women and
hair edges are a big deal do you have
them did Beyonce's Beyonce snatch them
with her fierceness it's pretty serious
stuff so why are people criticizing
Gabby's edges
well according to Twitter they don't
look nice enough for the Olympics
Gabby's competing in the Olympics not a
hair show you try doing the uneven bars
routine with a helicopter on your head
if Gabby if Gabby was worried about
keeping her edges laid she wouldn't be
at the Olympics she'd be on the couch
talking with you
you at home she at the Olympics plus
your Airlines bound to get a little
fuzzy when you're breaking a sweat
and breaking World Records
you